here
so to revisit
the
the daniel topic i've been texting with
daniel i just want to check with him if
i
um should speak about only everybody is
fine with that so there is
an issue that
daniel had contact with hang on i don't
want to get this right
um
yeah he had contact with someone who had
covet but he tested
negative a few times and then
he had a pcr test this morning i think
that's done neil
and the results would come after the
game so the organizer said
he should play but wear a mask
while playing which
is not what was a great beforehand
apparently with the
mask wearing and daniel
was not
a
fan of it and he specified that before
before the tournament and his yeah
not obliged according to him according
to the regulations so he's not on board
with it and that's why he's not he
hasn't shown up for the game
i believe
okay
yeah that was
becoming more and more likely with every
minute that he wasn't there that there
was some kind of a
not just an i overslept kind of reason
for this yeah
i'm not sure what the status is if he's
gonna forfeit over there some agreement
that has been made
before the game
or
during the game
i should point out that yeah i've seen
daniel where plenty must i do not think
that he's against wearing masks in
general at all it's just yeah that it
was very specifically agreed
um before the tournament that he doesn't
or the players don't have to wear
masks and i can to some extent obviously
it gets
dicey but understand that it can very
much affect your play
if you're not used to it
to wear a mask
for for an entire classical chess game
so yeah he does feel
strongly about it i should just read his
text like um
just mention that i'm openly against
playing in the mask and then we are
obliged to do it during the game
according to the regulation
um
yeah
yeah these are very difficult to comment
on from the outside
uh we've already had uh our share of
just where i'm asking lulu uh in chat
which
obviously is a viewpoint you can you can
have on this but
uh
if there is if there is agreements in
place uh
the people you know do feel strongly
about sticking to them